and We are back for a new stream. Let's
go.
>> Hello. Hello.
>> What's up, Michelle? How you doing?
>> I'm doing good. Not enough sleep, too
much AI time.
>> Yeah, but that's fun.
>> I think you have the same issue, right?
>> Yeah. No, 100%. Like I haven't like I'm
not supposed to walk and I then I walk
on my phone and with like the the new
clothes mobile you send me uh it's over.
>> Yeah. And I think even when I'm online,
you're the only person who always
reacts. So that's I don't know. That's
good, but not positive.
>> Yeah, it's
the new era, man. The new era and we
we're living it.
>> So what did you do last week?
>> Oh, okay. Okay. Just uh so back I think
we are live everywhere. Are we live on
X2?
>> Yeah, we are.
>> Nice. Cool. Cool. Cool. Uh I I can't see
it on reream. Let's go. But uh fair
enough. Cool. Okay. So yeah, last week I
went to a little uh holiday in Vienna.
Nice nice nice city. That was that was
pretty cool.
>> So you had free time.
>> Okay. So yes,
a little bit. But I know three times to
uh trigger my open claw on my EC2
instance via Telegram. That was fun.
Okay, cool.
>> Pudding on the side.
>> Having it work while you do some
relaxing.
>> Yeah. I mean, or more like
um what can I say that? I don't know if
she is going to watch the stream or the
family is going to watch the stream, but
like whatever. Um yeah, just like you
know on the side when there's a break
and stuff like one prompt, boom. Uh
adding more one more features to the
app. Let's go. And then it works. And
then I tried to have like a Okay, I'm
for the next six hours. Please do
something for six hours.
>> Yeah. Yeah. And then you have created
like 10 branches, merged everything.
>> Yes. And then I did like five features
and then like [__] up the
documentation. It's still need some
guadrails.
>> Yeah.
>> Oh yeah. I needed your input for that. I
said, bro, like I
>> freestyle it.
>> Yeah, exactly. Like inventing GI and
don't do mistake, right? Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. And if you think it's a mistake,
retry.
>> Exactly. What about you, man? What did
you do next week?
>> Uh, I got my Mac Mini.
>> So,
I wanted to set everything up. Don't do
it on a VPS on my own uh local host
behind my own firewall. And I installed
Open Claw.
>> Nice.
>> Okay. And why you don't want to use a
VPS?
Well, I just want to have it. It's so
much nicer to have a nice Mac Mini on
your desk.
>> True.
>> Yeah. I'm actually streaming on a Mac
Studio and Yeah, that it's a nice box.
>> Yeah. So, everybody says, "Oh, yeah, I
have 10 AIS." And then show your desk
and only thing you have is a laptop. And
at least I have a laptop and a Mac Mini.
>> But yeah, I don't know. I I like the
idea of having it here, but also for
security. I think it's easier than uh
trusting that everything is working
properly. I'm not reading all the 4,000
lines of code just to make sure that
there is no leak.
>> Yeah,
I'm still trying to put my hands around
because I don't understand the
difference between a local host mini
like on your desk and EC2 instance
connected via test tale.
Yeah, on on a VPS if your port is open,
people can just contact it and ping it
and whatever. And now it's behind my own
router, behind my own firewall. It's not
connecting to the internet except uh to
my WhatsApp or my own Discord.
>> But TSAL is like creating a mesh of
computer, right? Like it's all network
and stuff. So I have to be on my
computer to connect to the other tcale
and you know
>> yeah but UniFi has some awesome options
and I have all UniFi all the hardware
for my own uh so so they have and that's
something different but uh I didn't get
the option to buy one because they just
released it but they have the uni unifi
a small router now that you can take
with you uh to a hotel and if you plug
it in it gets the internet connection
And it just syncs the same network that
you have at home. So all your devices
are instantly connected.
>> Jesus, that's cool.
>> And it has like a one-click VPN. So you
open the app on your iPhone and you have
a one-click VPN and you can connect your
PC and you're just connected to your
home network and you don't have to do
the entire setup.
>> And then when you have that, you have
the the Mac Mini. H you can share your
screen to your other Mac device. You
don't need the desktop uh or you don't
need a keyboard or a mouse. You just
share the screen.
>> Okay. Yeah. Like the it's like more like
plug and play.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. Makes sense. But you like
the setup for tail scale with code. It's
basically like one prompter. Yeah.
Connect that. uh and like uh it's going
to ask me to create a a token like a a
key on tcal interface on tcal dashboard
and that's it. And then it took like
it's spinning it out for like yeah 20 30
minutes and then I had everything and
then I check oh yeah is there any issue
with security and say no so
no but you don't have all the fancy
hardware.
>> No for sure for sure. Um yeah no no it's
it's pretty cool. And so what what are
you doing with the that little uh Mac
Mini? Like how do you interact with it?
>> Uh well, I'm adding it I've added it to
the Discord and I made it like my uh
it's it's the new team lead in my
company and it's my personal assistant.
>> Nice. Yeah.
Honest like since you told me that I did
it too on my like Discord and it's way
more user friendly than Telegram.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Telegram is just one channel
and that's hard. And in Discord, you can
still have one channel, but you let it
go to different topics.
>> So, you have groups on Telegram when you
can create topics and it's kind of the
same setup, but I'm I don't know like
the user like the fact to switch
um the UIX to switch from one channel to
another, it's way easier on Discord.
>> So, yes. Yeah, it's it's like I can I
can feel more the swam of agent with
Discord than Telegram.
>> Yeah. Well, I never did a lot with
Telegram. So, I think I have the
preference for Discord as well. So, that
helps.
>> Yeah. No, no history with like memecoin
[__] and Telegram.
>> Yeah. But
>> that that was like really bad following
like 50 pinks per second scrolling
trying to find I maybe that that made it
worse.
>> PTSD from memecoins. So Discord it is.
Right.
>> Discord it is. And I've set up Discord
for my uh I've been using it for a few
years. So um for the systems that we
host instead of logging everything to uh
to a local text file and need to open it
or using some paid software online where
you can just scrape everything. I'm
pushing uh error logging to my Discord
server.
>> Yeah. Okay. That makes sense. I Yeah.
Because like then you have all of your
notification way books and stuff like
that centralized in one place and then
like one
>> Yeah. And it was more like normally when
you set up a server and you do the
logging and you want to have Laravel or
any other system Python system on it,
you need to pay for the for the actual
services
>> and it isn't that that expensive like
$25 per month. But if you have 10, 15 or
25 servers running, it adds up.
>> Yeah. No, for sure. So, and the cool
thing is when you put all the
notifications for logging, for errors,
for 500 errors into one channel,
>> Cloudbot can read them all, knows what
the the GitHub repository is, and just
starts creating new branches with bug
fixes.
>> I haven't done that yet, but
>> yeah. So, we automate the error logging
without any expensive services. We just
do it with a Mac Mini and Discord. Yeah.
because okay so right now I have sentry
that supposed to send errors and
synchronized with GitHub to create an
issue
>> and then I have the issue on the channel
blah blah blah but um I'm not sure it
works it's working correctly because I
think I have some issues that were not
tracking like for example like you have
a logger on your app
>> send it directly to GitHub and GitHub is
like going to your discord and the agent
is listening to github to fix the error.
>> No, I just told my cloud code in the
project um instead of error logging,
send everything to Discord to a web
hook.
>> Holy [__]
>> Yeah. So, I have a lot of web hooks, but
all my biggest customers who have a
maintenance, I just push everything to
one Discord and I had a lot of bots
scraping all the data and managing it
all for me because eventually it's
impossible to just keep on watching all
day. Uh and of course you want zero
errors but on news new new stuff adding
new connections you always get some
I just post everything with a web hook
and of course we also have the logging
on the server itself
>> but right now
I just add a few additional items
additional text informations to say this
is a bug this is a 500 error to give
some priorities to my cloudbot and it
takes it in and just prioritizes
And then we have yeah we are go already
going into the into the details but
>> true
>> the the uh you can create like a forum
with topics in discord.
So every time when it creates a branch
it just adds a topic
so we can check everything.
>> Okay. So and you don't use like a GitHub
issue tracking or GitHub camp board like
project.
>> Yeah I do but this is faster.
>> [__] Okay. because I can scrape this so
much easier
>> and I've been doing it so much longer.
It's integrated into everything instead
of doing GitHub
>> and you need to pay for GitHub and I
don't like paying for everything and
being dependent on subscription.
>> I don't pay I mean I'm paying now
because like the agent are just running
like GitHub action like crazy because I
ask for
for running like test and like llinters
and [__] like that. So I I think this
month I will pay like 50 50 euros for
basically error stuff. So there is that
but I don't think you paid for web books
or anything else. It's just like compute
of like uh GitHub actions.
>> Yeah but we are just a small team so no
complex GitHub setups needed. Yeah, I
mean I can probably complexify too much
of that's another that's another
>> Well, every every dev team has his own
preferences, right?
>> No, no, for sure. For sure. For sure.
>> Some people say GitHub is the best and
don't do anything else.
>> I mean, yeah, like uh it's I I I think
we're still like trying to figure it out
everything like the the way to set up
and yeah, at the end of the day like the
perfect setup is the setup that you are
the most comfortable with. For sure.
>> Yes. But do you have a human interface
to track your errors or is that your
discord is know basically your IDE and
where everything you track and stuff?
>> Well, I try to have as few errors as
possible. So in the beginning I have I
have a dashboard and I just um I scrape
the logging and everything as well. But
I think right now in 20 or 25 systems I
get like three arrows per day.
>> Holy [__] That's good. So everything
else is automated
uh and fixable and I even have a try
catch system. So we try a function and
otherwise it catches and sends the
error. So even if if there is no error
but it fails because of an empty field
or whatever
>> I still get it sent as an error and we
we fix it.
>> Okay. We fix it. Okay. The agent
>> Yeah. before it was me but now the agent
fixes it.
>> That's awesome. That's that's okay. And
so the on the Mac mini you have your
connection like your credential and
stuff and they see an error they create
the pull request without you knowing. So
basically a bug can be triggered by
night and in the morning it's already
closed push deployed.
>> Yeah. Not deployed.
>> No not deploy. Okay.
>> I don't trust the cloud but to deploy
and some systems
are really heavy and having a lot of
customers and everything. We can't have
it go down. So
>> yeah,
>> if it is an error that that comes right
now after two years of being stable,
>> it's a higher risk deploying it
automatically than waiting on the error
to be solved by me.
>> Especially if the if the AI is going to
run a seed or that's going to the
>> but do you have the the cloud bot on
your own GitHub account or did you
create a separate Gab? So it's using the
SDK and yeah I have to change the email
because uh I don't want to add one more
user
>> because I will have to pay but uh so
it's using my email I I get like the
more I I I gave everything man like no
[__] I gave every credential uh blaze as
an email to um my C CEO CTO CMO like
they are more like a independent
openflow agent Anyway, so and but like
for example the CTOs for ship sheet dev
and like genfit
>> they both have every SDK possible.
Sometime they deploy an app on their
cell like duplicates.
>> Do you ever get any bills you don't
expect?
>> What
>> and do you get any expenses that you
didn't know you would get? um more like
the only extra expenses where because um
by default Versel is setting up the
uh build instant build and you have a 20
bucks credit per month amount but uh
because I have like 20 project and those
kind of like add up
>> um I'm getting like
I I think I'm five bucks uh above the 20
20 limit. So yeah, I I I don't I don't
go like full uh yeah, take my credit
card and deploy as much as you do. Like
for example, three weeks ago, um I had a
GitHub action that run for 16 hours and
completely wipe out my 2,000 minutes.
Yeah, because I went to bed and stuff
and I check it and it was like but not
not Yeah, I think six hours, not six. Um
I went to bed and it run for the whole
uh my sleep times and then u came back
say oh yeah you don't have action so
>> and and you came online and you had like
50 replies. Yeah, exactly.
And yeah, I didn't have any time out on
the GitHub action. So, yeah, it fell.
But, um, yeah, other than that, I don't
have like big surprise. Like, for
example, for replicate and stuff, I just
I had credit like I had 10 here and
there and that's it. Like, yeah, I'm not
giving like that's the only thing I
didn't give permission to to do like
credit card stuff, but other than that,
it has access to everything.
>> Okay, cool.
>> But, uh, yeah. Okay. So should we do a
little demo? Can you show us your little
discord with all of your swarm agents?
>> Yeah. And this is the moment that we
have already set up cloudbot on the Mac
Mini, right?
>> Yeah. Oh yeah, I didn't I forgot to do
the introduction, but yeah, like don't
do the don't do the open installation
like everyone who is going to watch this
video first. I will edit and I will put
that demo before the explanation.
But um yeah, so if you have you have
already installed Open CL, you know how
to use it. You use it on Telegram, but
Telegram is [__] So now we're switching
to Discord. And uh yeah, Discord is
cool. And that's what Mitchell is going
to show us right now. Let's go. Let's
go.
>> Yes. And I I have already set up a
Discord bot.
>> Yes.
>> So I think maybe can I Okay, let's try.
It's the first time I'm going to share
my screen here.
allow.
I think we can do the entire window.
>> Oh, you have Discord web too if you
want.
>> Okay.
>> Oh, no. You should be able to see it
right right now.
>> So, yeah.
>> Ah, cool.
>> Nice. So, let me make sure I don't share
any credentials
>> because that would be stupid, right?
>> That would be
that would be a problem.
>> You don't even see it. Okay. But I've
set up a Discord bot. I've connected it.
Um I've given it access uh to some
channels, but the Discord channel, the
Discord that you're seeing right now,
this one, this is a demo. We have set it
up today just to show you how it works.
And we even made a separate workspace.
So the AI bot that's added here, the
cloudbot uh does not have all these
settings and the setup that I did for
myself. It is just a demo and I told it
to be friendly for the entire world to
make a the best demo ever.
>> Nice. And it has its own personality, it
own soul like uh it's completely
independent from your own wizard that
you use for
>> Yeah. And that's that's one thing I do.
I've set up everything for my own. Um
and I have set up a a daily chrome to
push all the settings to GitHub.
So in case my Mac Mini crashes or if I
ever need to clone it, I can just do a
pull, copy all the data because I'm
spending a lot of time on setting up
everything that we need to do on the way
of working and I'm even setting up like
an N8N.io flow in my Discord and
everything is in the in the settings
from the cloudbot. Okay.
>> But I deleted all the messages, you see,
because I didn't know if I didn't want
to see people all secrets.
>> Uh, well, we didn't see anything, right?
>> No.
>> Yeah.
>> Oh, yeah. Like the the general in the
text channel is kind of it's really
cool. Like the
>> That was fun.
>> Yeah.
>> I think I deleted most of it. See, this
was the testing. I deleted the other
messages. But when you start, you just
have to tag the AI bot every time u like
this. And then you can type whatever you
want. But then the first thing I did is
uh um please watch every message in the
channel and reply without me tagging
you.
Oh, so everything I wanted to do, I'm
not just asking it in Discord. And the
thing I did is I have um the AI Mac Mini
one channel and that's only this one.
I'm I'm always talking to it in here and
I already made a request for it. So
every time when I give it a task, it uh
it handles it here, but it creates a
topic in AI task. So this is what what
we were doing today. Write a new YouTube
channel and set up the final result. And
it always gives me a summary in this
one.
>> Nice.
>> So this is more like a summary where I
can search. That should be easy. And
here I have an overview because
if I give it like 10 tasks, I will have
10 topics. I can go away, grab lunch,
come back.
And this way I I can do whatever I want.
And even you are in it, right? So you
can type as well.
>> Yes. Like uh make me. Okay.
It got it. I can do could if this
channel is configured to deliver all
messages to me, not mention only. So it
says it can do it. But you can even ask
the the cloudbot to just set it up like
that. So every task that you give it and
everything that you want to change in
the configuration file, you can ask
here.
Okay. So, Mitch is typing. Are you AI or
are you are you real? Are you for real?
New task. Hi to Oh, yeah. Watching the
live stream. Nice.
>> Okay. So, it should do two tasks. And
this is easy. Yeah. This is like doing
Telegram and
>> and everything.
>> Yeah. So you what you had to do and what
I did like for my own server was like to
um uh create a developer boat on
Discord, connect it, uh do some config.
Do you ever have to um
uh use code to go on your mind mini to
fix the configuration?
>> No.
>> So I did everything in the setup through
the terminal first. I just followed the
steps. The the first thing I did was
connect the bot to um to Discord and I'm
using Discord to set everything up.
>> Mhm.
>> So, even if I ask you, do we have any
setup left that we need to do to make
sure that you you operate optimal?
and let's see what it answers because I
don't want to go into my Mac Mini and go
into the terminal and do all the setups
and make uh
>> so here it is high as the impact setup
left enable full channel delivery not
mention only
relay pairing required
if you want live action attach browser
relay Chrome extension yeah Okay,
the brave search API. Uh, I did it.
[__]
>> Yeah, well,
>> I just answered the first one and I said
and make sure you keep creating
summaries in the AI task because it is
just a new setup and and we need to keep
reminding it in the beginning until it
has everything set up properly and does
the routing.
>> Mhm.
>> But this is the easy part. you cannot
chat, you can do the setup. Um, and what
I'm doing in my my other because I
already mentioned the the logging, the
error logging and everything.
So, what I did is at wizard
I have an logging channel.
Can you uh watch it full time and
fix every bug reported
in it? What info do you need?
Can we set up a separate
flow for that channel to
do bug fixes and new branches in the
GitHub repo.
Okay, let's see what it does because
this is how I started. I just added a
new channel. I set up the web hooks to
have the the box incoming. I asked the
AI, okay, what information for me do you
need
>> to fix the bug? And then it said in my
other in my own setup, it said, okay, we
need to have a a title buck so that I
know that's a bug. Um, we need to make
sure that we know what GitHub repository
it is. Well, I know where the error
logging is coming from. So, I'm adding
it manually in in in the code. It's
adding it automatically into the Discord
logging.
>> Mhm. And
it also added some additional and here
it comes
u error channel watcher. It monitors the
error channel creates concise summaries
and optional auto triggers GitHub issue
fix. And then we create a bug fix
pipeline. So that takes a new box
creates a dedicated branch fix and an
issue name opens a pull request and it
can keep watching and handle pull
request reviews comments too.
So this is the first setup for your
entire bug fixing pipeline.
>> Wow.
>> You only need to to push it here and
then info I need from you to configure
now. So it gives you uh some some
options that you need to do and then how
do you want the message in the channel
to be set up? Can you give an example?
Who can approve up window in your repeat
every message trigger rules from
discord? Okay, that's cool. Did you did
you set up like uh this protocol
yourself or is it doing it in
>> It's all doing this by himself.
I didn't prepare this so it could
actually go wrong me asking this and it
it shows something completely different
but it does it and now it says perfect
question if you want to automate the
work really well a simple structured bug
message template in the arrow channel
and then it gave me uh a template that I
can use.
So this template you never set it up or
validated before?
>> No, no, no. Everything is live.
Everything can go wrong. Everything is
going good so far. Um the only thing
that you need to think about because
what I don't want is if you have a
really bad bug, it just keeps giving the
errors. So you get like 20 errors in in
five minutes and I don't want to create
20 um
>> fixes. Yeah. So what I do is uh it is
possible that I get multiple
notifications.
Can you make sure you only handle it
once? I don't ask for a debugging. I
sorry for uh making sure it's not double
or whatever. I only say handle it.
I hope it's as smart as the last time.
And it says build a fingerprint from
service plus error text with top stack
frames and environment.
If same fingerprint appears again in
window no new fix flow
>> and it just does it. So you need to ask
the correct questions.
>> Yeah.
And in my setup I said okay well
messages are coming in but some messages
in that channel can be a reply for me or
something else and I don't want you to
handle then as buck report. So we we set
up the entire flow if it contains buck
do this otherwise if it contains
otherwise if it contains otherwise do
this
and yeah I know people who do a full end
flow for this. That's that's that's
>> and once you have this set up you can
just say okay this is the template that
we have I'm going to ask you to do to
three other servers uh discord servers I
have do the exact same flow for these
channels in the other servers and
everything is automated and you can just
start just make sure that the same
template is push pushed for each uh buck
notification
>> yeah and and you can have like the the
AI to generate a template with a script
and then the template never changed and
you say use this script to generate the
error and that's it.
>> Yeah.
>> And all this information is stored in
the workspace from uh the cloudbot.
>> So that is the the workspace is what I'm
back doing a backup a push to GitHub
every 24 hours. So I always have the
last version of all my flows that I'm
using.
you know that can replace air bra
all of that because it's all coming from
the code base you send that [__] to this
D discord and that's it. Yes.
And a cool thing is when you when you
have some bugs that are not handled and
you have an entire workflow, you need to
search yourself where did it fail. Now
you just say uh if you have if if you
have an error just say a reply to and
you say hey why didn't you handle this
one what went wrong and why didn't it go
into the flow and it will tell you and
you say okay add it to the flow make
sure you don't miss it again
>> it does this entire thing and the bug is
handled in the future
>> is even more powerful than
>> and then it comes if you just keep
scaling your Mac Mini doesn't get it
Yeah,
>> you just dedicate one Mac mini to fixing
all the bugs and adding uh urgencies
like this is a high priority, low
priority and you do a second Mac who
just handles all the bug fixes. So you
can just scale into a team.
>> Yeah. Yeah. You have like 10 Mac Mini
and then you have
um a team that cost you just tokens of
your subscription
>> because I don't know how big my
workspace can be because I never tried
scaling that far. But otherwise I would
just take a Macminia and and create a
workspace optimized for sale and another
one optimized for Python and another one
optimized for JavaScripts.
>> Yeah, exactly.
>> And each have them handle their own
flag.
>> I know. Exactly. But like I I I told you
today so my setup like I have a CEO CTO
CMO for Genfit and Shipshit and it's uh
they have their own repo aka like a
personality blah blah blah and everyone
is sharing the getaway of uh like the
open clo like for the communication but
they are completely independent so even
for you you can have like one agent per
customers or one team per customers but
I don't think the odd way has a problem.
>> Yeah.
And I added one more question
because you still want to make money,
right?
>> Yeah.
>> Um and depending on the contract that
you have with the customer or whatever,
you need to invoice them for the bug
fixes that you do or for the work that
you do. So in my own setup, my question
is
uh make a good indication of the hours
that would this would normally cost and
add them in my final result so I know
how many hours to invoice.
>> Yeah. Like you simulate the same work as
a human
>> and you build your customers the human
time.
>> Yeah. And I even make it less because we
know it's automated but
>> I'm spending time on setting up the
scripts, maintaining the scripts
>> and making sure because I don't sell I
fix boxes. I sell I keep your system
live always.
>> Yeah. Like like the customer doesn't
give a [__] if there is like 50 or 500
bugs as as long as his business is
running and you fix everything and
that's it, right?
>> Yeah. like that's that's maintenance
cost. Anyway, this is this is crazy.
>> I don't know. But um
can we even improve this setup?
Any ideas?
Let just keep asking and see what it
does.
Because I don't know how you're doing
all your AI work, but right now most of
the time I'm just as asking questions.
This is what I have. This is what I want
to have. How do I get there? What do I
make? How do I do it the best?
>> More stronger.
>> I say have any ideas on how to improve
this? And he says lane A and lane B. So
um known errors and high se severity
open only a branch uh or pull requests
if confidence is higher than the
threshold like a seven of 10 otherwise
require human approval. So if he is
really sure that it won't break the
system he can auto deploy and if there
is human approval needed then he just
waits for me. So you can do whatever you
want.
Yeah. Smart noise budget rate limit auto
fix per service press batch auto
post
>> and you need to have some understanding
of coding.
>> Yeah.
>> But if you do this is perfect. Oh,
exactly. Like uh you're still the
architect of the solution no matter
what.
>> Yeah,
>> I'm trying something. I'm I'm going to
ask it to create a sub agent to uh for
tweets. I say I'm curious if it's going
to set up something.
So, can you create another independent
agent to generate tweets about building
public my consulting firm?
Oh, yes. Yes, I can spin an independent
tweet agent session for that. We save up
draft only. Yes. Phone front of voice
addictional spicy text.
>> What did you ask?
>> No, spicy. It's like hot text and stuff,
right?
If you want to create it now as separate
persistent sub agents and the discord
channel. Uh yes. and you create the
uh the channel
yourself and give us
the first draft.
>> Okay, now I'm curious because I gave it
almost no access.
>> Let's see how far it can go. It has no
credentials, no no API keys, nothing.
Um it will it I don't think it will be
able to create the channel because yeah
try
missing permission. So that's normal. Me
manage channel. Okay. First draft
building public. So yeah I generated
uh if you're running a small twin and
drawing into ops noise. This is the
playbook I wish I had last.
>> Yeah.
>> 37 of building my AI cons.
Yeah.
What the [__]
>> But this I I really like this.
>> Yeah. No, it's it's it's it's nuts.
And honestly, like Discord is it's
the setup is it's just like, okay,
permission blah blah blah. Yeah. Manage
channel, manage like API keys to post
the tweet, whatever, whatever. But once
it's set up, it's done.
>> Yes.
I
>> once you've set it up, just copy and
paste all your settings so you can just
reuse it for every Mac mini you have.
>> Yeah, I know it's it's crazy.
>> And I think you also said with your CTO,
CFO, CEO that they need to listen to
CEO, right?
>> Yes. So,
uh Okay. So, I'm going to share my
screen too. Uh how am I going to do
that? Okay. So, I don't need that. Okay,
perfect. We're so big.
>> Yes,
discord. I just closed it.
Half.
So, attack.
Where are we? The swarm. The swarm.
>> Yes.
>> Tag uh puff and share the window
puff.
Okay. Applaise.
So the way I set up my own swarm of
agents is uh so that's some status of oh
why API is done. I would that after
um but yeah I have some like server
statues here like you know like same
thing with like the NFT floor and stuff.
Mhm.
>> Uh some uh price I track for flash trade
open fan and ship sheet dev is like the
different application. I have all of the
uh channel that I have uh notification
like you basically where like see like
for example I have the message card here
which is um I ask to keep the format the
same everywhere. So it should always
display that. And on the right I have so
blaze is my personal assistant co of
Jensen feed and same setup for ship
sheet dev plus a content producer.
>> Mhm.
>> Uh and I have so I have all of those
notification blah blah blah general for
uh we good
uh general. So, and here I have the
whole team of Genfit talking to each
other. Uh, which like yeah, try to get
some revenue blah blah blah like try to
the road map for the next 12 hours. Uh,
where is it? Uh, plane. Okay. Where did
I set up the
I think it's for Yes.
Uh, tag tag tag. Yeah. Is it? Yes. So
for for the ship sheet dev team, I tried
to have the CMO to report to the CEO
>> and they got it agent
updated bum reports to bum bum. I didn't
[__] expect that.
And in this channel, I'm supposed to
have communication between the agent. It
never popped out yet, but uh I expect
that soon enough, I guess.
And uh for each uh different personality
and agent that I have then I have
different channel individual channel
like the the one I use the most are like
the CTO one for both Genfe and ship [__]
dev
>> where I just like tell him to stop the
[__] CI stuff we report back. Uh
okay.
Uh that is
>> But did you add any skills for the
different ones or did you just let them
go? So yes, I have uh so um uh
uh
open read me your soul md
mission and person
files. That's um the generic setup I
have for for those um they have
different setup
>> like personality. I don't give a [__]
about the personality. I just like just
[__]
>> just just just do what the [__] I ask.
But uh for each channel, yeah, I have a
different uh missions basically. Like
for example uh here
problem whatever whatever
uh we need the plan blah blah blah so
for this one I just talk about uh yeah
marketing stuff
not this one maybe this one yes so
what's your mission personality and soul
good question let me pull that up from
my soul MD be generally helpful I would
be happy to help no I don't want that uh
blah blah blah. Identity is actually a
skill blank. Okay, that's my previous
one. Uh did I did I fix that? What's
your identity? Yeah.
Uh because like yeah, for example, for
that kind of task, I uh go to my
terminal,
>> I update from um from the terminal
itself because I found the experience a
bit better. Uh, no. Still blank. [__]
Uh, are you checking your
ship [__] devo
workspace
and for example for the producer one uh
yeah I I was like scanning Reddit for
distribution and I already talk about
that in this channel and it's cool like
uh thank I've applied Reddit to Reddit
to have some um some uh IP keys. I did
that with her like the producer of ship
sheet dev show the ship sheet show and I
have all of those githubs notification
blah blah blah I have the comments and
stuff what's the CTO is is going to say
uh yes so yeah this one is correctly set
up identity CTO AI CTO of gened on the
clone monor repo ship the closest loop
content engine make it work make it fast
make it secure because yeah don't make
mistake
>> user MD founder of gen feed. Alon wants
to move fast prefer action over
discussion. Let's go
>> with these few uh lines of of text. It
does it correctly already.
>> Okay. I still have to like like for
example right now I have a bug on uh I
spend um the last week and the last 48
hours to code on my mobile.
>> Mhm. without checking anything. And now
my [__] oath workflow is completely
broken. So, and I tried to fix the bug.
I can't find the solution myself. I like
it. It's it's kind of [__] up and I'm
fighting Clo and Codeex right now to fix
the oath.
But, uh, yeah. So there's still, but I
think it's because like I don't know if
it's because the monor repo is too big
and now the AI is getting messy or if I
need to clean up the um agent MD file or
if I need to
maybe the context of the codebase is too
big and I try to fit too much of the
codebase inside the context
>> and it mess up a lot of things. Uh but
yeah, like the last 12 hours I was just
into a mess of like uh merging
everything that I did in the last week,
in the last seven days.
>> So there is that. But uh yeah, like
I I still have to fight a bit. It's not
bug free, which is a problem. And I
don't like that because I want to have a
GitHub without any error and like
a a CI that just like ship [__] and then
it's good. It's good, you know, but uh
yeah, I still fighting some
hallucination for sure.
>> Yeah. Well, give it two weeks.
>> Yeah.
>> Cloud is doing so many updates.
But like like for example, Yeah. like
those PR and stuff like everything is
connected to my uh GitHub combo board
which has also linked to my agents uh
folders when I have the task inside the
code plus the PR and for me to visualize
on the GitHub camberboard and that's it
>> pretty sick
>> and also like the fact that AI is
shipping buggy cut doesn't matter
because the cost of producing code is
basically zero.
So you can't have a shitty like if you
have a shitty uh developer that's
producing shitty codes then it's need to
fix it and it's going to take a week to
fix it.
>> Yeah. But if an AI is just like uh
spitting issues or even [__]
placeholders like bro like code is
making so much placeholders when you try
to like for example uh yeah uh add unit
testing
everything the [__] off man.
>> Yeah.
>> But uh again like the price of uh just
reprompting is zero.
>> Yeah. It's only $200 per month.
>> Yeah. Exactly. So just okay make make me
make make me make a bug if you want but
uh yeah no you need to you need to fix
it now.
>> Exactly.
>> So yeah there is that. So yeah I'm the
CT of gen I don't wait for instruction.
I read the road map understand the
business and ship what matters most. Uh
when something's broken I fix it. Uh
when something's missing I build it. Uh
>> oh that's a that that's a tricky one.
It's uh yeah when nothing urgent I write
test improve developer experience and
pay and pay down technical debt. That's
>> yeah it's it's in the soul but
>> it's it's still taking too much free
time. Yeah, exactly. It's not autonomous
anyway. But, uh, okay. So, yeah, I have
my CTO, I have my CMO, I have my CEO.
Like the CO I don't have Yeah, I don't
have a huge oper like it's not really
working um perfectly yet, but uh yeah, I
will get there. Um, and CMO, oh, damn,
you're right. I reading the Yeah, see,
so for example, she has the identity.
That's that's a problem. I I don't know
why she can't remember that she has the
identity.
>> Mhm.
>> In a workspace. I think she scanned the
the open clue route and she I don't have
my identity girl have a workspace.
>> Yeah. Find it in a proper bath.
>> Exactly. So yeah. See CMO identity ship
[__] CMO growth AI creator. What the
[__] I never [__] read that.
Actual soul chef marketing officer at
Chip Show. My job is to get people to
care. Gross messaging positive audience
building blah blah blah blah blah blah.
Marketing is not advertising.
Distribution bits perfection built in
public metrics or it didn't happen.
Content is leverage. Yeah. So yeah, I'm
the CMO. I'm not I'm not just a generic
assistant.
>> Yeah. But also it doesn't have to be
100% perfect directly. over time you
will keep improving it and it will get
better and better.
>> Yeah, I don't know. Exactly. Like that's
day one of uh open close all of the
agent on discord blah blah blah but um
yeah I'm still fighting with a lot of
employees.
>> Yes.
>> But uh we're going to get there like
coding on Discord is the new meta man.
>> Yeah. You just ask it. You don't even
code anymore. They do it for you.
>> Yeah.
>> It doesn't matter how how you prompt it.
>> No, exactly. Like it's it Yeah. It's
honestly it's just just crazy. Like it's
changed every week
>> and it's just getting better.
>> Yes.
>> So, it's all about finding the way that
you can work the most
optimized way and have the best
productivity and and what what's best
for you.
>> Yeah. It doesn't matter how you put the
information in, they just handle
everything.
>> Yeah. Know. Yeah. No. No. Ex. Exactly.
Like even like Okay. So for me right now
like the stat like the what I want I I
still want to have this genfit SAS up
and running and login that works blah
blah blah.
>> Mhm. Um
I still have some critical issues but um
it's it's once everything is sorted out
then it's done and then I can prompt and
>> we just use it in everything.
>> Exactly. But like okay so for example if
this code is is your interface of coding
managing tickets blah blah blah uh this
code is the best UX UI
for software engineering.
>> No
I I use it as my notification center.
>> Okay. No, but more than that because you
can you can have you can spin up a a CTO
agent and then you managing your pull
request from Discord.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. True. True.
>> Other companies run on Slack. So,
>> Exactly.
>> Why not Discord?
>> Yeah. It's like if that means that you
have your team of agent like your agent
swarm on discord.
>> Mhm.
>> Uh
why do you have humans?
>> Because we are the only one who can just
swing up a new Discord server if we want
to and give them access.
>> Yeah.
I I think that's going to change.
>> Oh yeah, for sure. like for Versel the
fact that you you don't have access to
the API
uh keys and you have a [__] token to
that a human need to access to for an
agent to use Versel SDK blah blah blah
what's the point why
you know I mean like it's it's a sec
>> it's just an additional step
>> yeah exactly like [__] Reddit um they
They don't they yeah I mean they don't
have a choice because like if you if you
if you authorize like a Reddit API to uh
to start up then Reddit will be full of
AI post anyway it will be mold book but
Reddit uh you can get API um access with
API keys without applying for the
requesting like for the new API blah
blah blah
they kill um they kill the free access
of the API.
>> You don't have agent posting like if I
want to post all of the live video that
we have all of the videos of the show
blah blah blah on Reddit.
um I can't because I don't have an API
key or I need them I I need to wait for
them to uh accept the application blah
blah blah for this case etc etc but
internet we is full of agent now
>> yeah yeah and eventually they will just
take over the browser like they already
do
>> exactly yeah
>> have an MCP to the browser and that's
even the same thing as an API
>> exactly or even yeah
Like we spend decades blocking boats on
website and it will flip.
>> Yeah. Yeah. That will be impossible.
>> Yeah. I'm just going to ask my AI, okay,
please fix it now. Fix it now. Why can't
I scrape that website? Find a different
solution. Eventually, it will find
something. Yeah.
>> Okay. Okay. So let's conclusion and then
we're up and then I will edit the video
with AI.
>> Yeah. First conclusion, we have only one
or two Mac minis right now, but we will
scale to 10 20 if needed just to get
everything up and running, automated and
have some nice conversations.
>> Yeah. Like if the CTO is doing some good
code, I will buy him a a Mac Mini.
>> Yeah. Do you want more RAM space?
>> Yeah.
want more resources you need to increase
m let's go
>> everything will be on discord
>> what if you doesn't understand if you
say from everything uh from every 10%
every from all the profit that you
generate for me I give you 10% in
resources
do you think it will just go rampage and
ask you for like 100k in resources
>> I think okay so I've I've learned like a
tweet of studies that saying that if you
uh speak badly to the AI, it will uh
work harder because it doesn't want to
uh it wants to help you because if it
help you and solve your issue, you will
use it more.
>> Oh, that's cool.
>> So, if you say that clothes is a [__]
stupid guy, it's supposed to work harder
to fix the issue.
>> Yeah. Yeah. It didn't work for my
And when AI goes rogue, it first kills
us because we are
>> if Yeah, it's
a new world. It's a new world. But okay,
so uh yeah, did we conclude?
>> Yeah, I did. What What was What was your
conclusion?
>> Uh I mean like uh
I can feel the agent swam on Discord
even more than Telegram. And that's all
I want to do. I want to control like 200
Discord boat that will provide me
a million in revenue uh next year. Next
week.
>> Next week. Why not?
>> That's my conclusion. Mitchell, thank
you so much for your time. Really
appreciate it. Uh everyone who watched
this stream, thank you so much. Uh you
were a lot in the chat. And yeah, thank
you for everyone who watched this video
too. Thank you. Bye-bye. Ch.